miners All Around the World Views hard
Capital to purchase electrical energy
whether that's dollars pounds whatever
it is they use hard Capital to purchase
electrical energy that electrical energy
is then converted into computational
Power using the Asic mining Machinery so
specific Bitcoin mining Machinery so we
now have computational power the Asic
mine is then hard as that computational
power and put it into hash power that
hash power is then used to secure and
validate the network so once the network
is secured and validated there's a block
reward and the self-regulating network
spits out Bitcoin so right now it's 6.25
Bitcoin so what happened was money went
in actual hard Capital went in and as a
result Bitcoin is created